how much of the work is done in the edit
that's another question i'm curious
about yeah and how much do you
sort of anticipate that
like when you're actually shooting
are you thinking of the final
story as it appears on screen
or are you just collecting as a human
collecting little bits of story here and
there and in the edit is where most of
the storytelling happens i've developed
this sort of mental paradigm for myself
over the years um
that speaks to that and and i call it
the three creations right and so
when i'm doing a film the first creation
for me is
you know
my preconception or visualization of
what the film is going to be before i
shoot it right so i have this this
entire vision of of what a film film's
gonna be um and and sometimes it could
be pretty specific like i'll i'll think
through the scenes if i if i know the
locations and everything i'll have this
idea of what i'm gonna create right
and then i'm there filming
right and always without fail
reality is something altogether
different
than what i thought it would be but it's
still good to have the original idea
yeah yeah but if i tried to hold to that
original vision right and to create a
film out of that idea they'd be crap all
the films would be so we i have to adapt
i have to evolve my approach and then
embrace what is actually occurring with
the people actually doing it and then
re-envision so that re-envisioning is
very active during the entire filming
process and so that's the second
creation that's the
the rethinking and re-visualizing
based on what we're actually
experiencing and seeing what this film
is going to be
and then
i finished filming right and we bring
the hard drives back and we plug in the
hard drives um in the edit bay
and
oftentimes you know because it's two of
us filming most of the time
i haven't seen all the footage
because in the field it's all about just
filming right and then just transferring
the footage and getting safely you know
cloned to multiple drives i don't have a
chance to review everything i can't do
rushes like you do on a large feature so
because i'm filming half of it i know
what i've filmed right but i haven't
seen everything the director photography
has filmed right so the next stage for
me is reviewing every single frame of
what's been filmed
and that's where
discovery happens the third time right
or second time rather is
wow
now i thought we'd film this
but actually
um there's this over here and then i
have to open up this second vision and
turn in and transform it into a third
vision for the film based on what's
actually on the hard drive so so you're
is this like a daily process so what i
do the fruit my process is that
once if it's a really difficult project
i'll take a break before i go through
this yeah just just for healing you know
and and some space away and fresh eyes
and usually that's about a month
and then once i reengage i re-engage
whole hog i re-engage fully and it and i
review every single frame and as i do
that i create a spreadsheet
um and for hunger war that spreadsheet
was i don't know 1500 lines long or
something where it's basically log notes
and i and i watch every scene and i take
notes
and i i know really what we have and
once i've gone through that process that
takes about a month and i really know
what we came back with i create an
outline for the film from that and
that's the third visioning right
that's usually completely different than
my original vision for the film to some
extent right but i have to stay open to
that entire process
or or i'd be trying to create something
that i can't really create
so i think if that's those are the three
creations for me that's so cool to to
know what we have
uh just to lay it all out
and to load it in into your mind yeah
because like
this is the capture of reality we have
it's a very kind of scientific process
too because um
you know in science you collect a bunch
of data about a phenomena yeah and now
you have to like analyze that data but
now your phenomena is long gone
yeah yeah right right now you just have
the data just the data and you have to
uh write a paper about it like analyze
the data it's the similar things
you have to like load it all in where's
the story
how
how how do you
that last probably profound
piece of
doing the editing like in your mind like
what
uh how to lay those things out well it's
almost like the scientific process right
i have a hypothesis
a creative hypothesis right not a
scientific one yes and but then i'm
testing the hypothesis during the course
of filming right and i have to stay true
to what the data tells me in the end
creatively so it's very similar to the
scientific processes i don't know what
we should
we should probably coin that yeah that's
a pretty good creative
scientific process or something like
that
but then you
actually do the edit and then you watch
that's also uh iterative in a sense
because maybe
uh when you have a film that's 20 30 40
minutes or if it's feature line
uh
like it and
do you ever have it where it sucks
like it's not is there a stage where it
sucks like a stage where you're right
right
like it's where he's like no this is not
this is not what i was like when it's
all put together in this way this
doesn't this is not working right this
is not right
or do you
is it always like an incremental step
towards better and better it's
incremental yeah it's incremental yeah
and there's always some moment in the
editing process where there's a
breakthrough
where suddenly i understand how it fits
together
more fully and you have to be like you
said resilient you have to be patient
that that moment will come yeah exactly
are you ultra self-critical or are you
generally optimistic and
patient
i don't think those are mutually
exclusive right so you just oscillate or
you or they're like dance partners
they're dance partners yeah yeah
definitely dancing all the way through
the process
you